[bleep] WEIRDO WHO'S JUST LIKE,
HOW ABOUT WE GO TO THEM
AND SAY,
ALL RIGHT, LET'S SAY
I MADE THIS MUCH MONEY
OVER THIS PERIOD OF TIME,
AND I'LL PAY THIS KIND OF TAXES,
AND I'LL PLEA BARGAIN,
AND HE HAD IT NEGOTIATED
WHERE HE WAS GONNA
DO TWO YEARS IN PRISON.
AND THEN THE JUDGE,
THEY SAID, LIKE,
WE'RE NOT GONNA
ACCEPT YOUR PLEA,
BUT WE'RE GONNA TAKE PART OF
YOUR PLEA THAT SAID YOU EARNED
THIS MUCH MONEY
AND BUST YOU FOR TAXES,
AND--AND SENTENCE YOU
TO 11 YEARS IN PRISON, SO...
WHOA, WHAT THE [bleep]?
I THOUGHT WE HAD A DEAL HERE?
THEY PUT HIM AWAY.
THAT'S WHEN THEY STARTED
GIVING HIM LIKE, YOU KNOW,
MEDICAL TESTS AND PSYCH TESTS
AND STUFF, AND THAT'S--
YOU KNOW, 'CAUSE REALLY,
THEY KNEW NOTHING ABOUT HIM.
OH, HE'S GOT A 95 I.Q.
HE'S NOT THAT SMART.
HE'S THIS BIG, WEIRD
[bleep] MOOK.
OH, YOU GOT A 90 I.Q.,
BUT YOU SURE KNEW WHO TO KILL,
AND THAT'S PRETTY SMART.
[laughs]
OH, AND HE STARTED
PEEING PUS
WHEN HE WAS
[bleep] 18 YEARS OLD
AND HE DIDN'T [bleep] SAY
ANYTHING ABOUT IT.
[cough]
SYPHILIS.
[both laughing]
HE JUST IGNORED PUS COM--
COMING OUT OF HIS [bleep].
[laughs]
I MEAN, RIGHT?
GAH, PUS IS COMING OUT
OF MY [bleep]!
WHAT IS IT?
NOTHING.
WHAT ARE YOU GONNA DO?
I'M GONNA STOP THINKING
ABOUT IT.
GOOD IDEA.
[laughs]
HEY, AL, HOW ABOUT
ONE PENICILLIN SHOT?
NOPE.
LET'S IGNORE IT.
AND, YOU KNOW,
HE'S AFRAID OF NEEDLES,
AND SYPHILIS
ROTS HIS BRAIN.
SOON AFTER, HE BECOMES
A [bleep] BABBLING IDIOT.
DO YOU KNOW HE--HIS--HE WANTED
HIS NICKNAME TO BE "SNORKY"?
[laughs]
I WANT TO BE CALLED "SNORKY."
WE'RE GONNA CALL YOU
"SCARFACE."
NO, I WANT TO BE CALLED
"SNORKY."
BUT WHEN HE GOT OUT OF JAIL,
HE REALLY QUICKLY
WANDERED AWAY INTO, LIKE,
A IDIOT WHO WOULD, LIKE,
PUT A FISHING POLE
INTO HIS, LIKE,
POOL IN HIS BACKYARD,
LIKE, HOPING TO CATCH FISH.
[laughs]
I IMAGINE THEY JUST
MADE COMMENTS LIKE,
HEY, WHY IS HE FISHING
IN HIS OWN POOL?
WELL,
HE'S A SYPHILITIC MORON.
SYPHILITIC MORON?
WHAT'S THAT?
IT'S A GUY WHO HAS HAD
A PORTION OF HIS BRAIN
EATEN AWAY BY HIS OWN
[bleep] PUS.
HE--HE'S [bleep] UP.
HE'S--HE'S A MORON.
HE'S LIKE A FIVE-YEAR-OLD.
WOW, BECAUSE HE HAD SEX
WITH WHORES AND GOT, LIKE,
A DIRTY DICK AND HE DIDN'T
DO ANYTHING ABOUT IT?
PRETTY MUCH.